Should I eat gluten-free sourdough bread with a cancer history?
And I've considered making my own sense there's so many ingredients of the store-bought
brands which I purchase regularly.
Um, okay, so, first of all, gluten is gluten-good for cancer.
Well, gluten typically is not a direct feeder of cancer, so it's not going to be a fuel source
of cancer. So some people will say, I stopped eating gluten because of my cancer.
Well, there can be a lot of good things in that statement, but gluten is typically not going
to be a direct fuel source for cancer. Other than why should, or should a cancer patient stop
eating gluten? Well, the benefit of stop of limiting gluten is that gluten is so pro-inflammatory.
So remember, we're trying to kill cancer cells. We don't need to be, you know,
splitting our army to fight different things. And if we are eating an inflammatory diet, which gluten
would be, you know, number one on that inflammation list and then bad oils and things like that would
be in that category as well. But if we're causing more inflammation in our gut and in our brain,
it's going to be more difficult to fight cancer and kill cancer cells. So you want to, you know,
clean up your diet as best as possible so that your body can focus on what you want it to focus on. So
that being said, going gluten-free as a cancer patient has its benefits. Going gluten-free,
even if you don't have cancer has its benefits. Same reasons I just gave. So gluten is so inflammatory.
But in that understanding, if I'm going to start eating gluten-free foods, you're often going to
get foods that are not organic. And then you're going to get foods like this question says
that you're going to get foods that have a lot of different ingredients that you don't want to be
eating. So that is an issue as well. So you have to balance it out. What would be the best thing
to do? Well, the best thing to do would be to make your own bread if you want to eat bread.
And the other part of this question, sourdough bread has its own benefits. So many people who
are not cancer patients and are eating a gluten-free diet find that they can eat gluten-free sourdough
bread with very little problem or much less problem than if they eat regular gluten bread.
And they switch over from a gluten-free product to a sourdough bread. But if you're going to
start making your own, you could make your own out of a clean gluten-free flower. And then you're
solving both problems. You're not getting the gluten at all. And you're using a clean flower
organic flower, if you can find it, an organic gluten-free flower. Best thing would be to make your own
flower with organic materials that's gluten-free. And then make your own sourdough, start with your
own culture and make your own sourdough bread. Now, you know, obviously it sounds like you have
the ability to do that. Now, the negative issue of making your own sourdough is that you're committed
to making bread almost every day. And unless you're making it as a ministry and giving it away.
But it can be overwhelming for people, for the law law. Now, you can make it every day for two
months and freeze it. And that's another solution that you could go off and not make it for three months.
So there's different things that you could do. But yes, can you make your own gluten-free sourdough
would that be good for a person with cancer? Well, it's certainly a great option. You're not getting
the gluten and you're getting the benefits of sourdough. So I would say, yes, go for it. Stay gluten-free,
isn't always on everybody's list. But on everybody's list, I put limit gluten because gluten is so
inflammatory. So that would be the last suggestion.